- [Narrator] Delivering
millions of COVID-19 vaccines
involves distribution centers,
refrigerated trucks and
cold storage facilities.
And each of these could
be a target for hackers.
- COVID has been just a golden opportunity
for cyber criminals and they've
taken full advantage of it.
- [Narrator] Since the
start of the pandemic,
there have been attempts
to scam individuals
and businesses for money,
as well as steal vaccine research
or hold data ransom for a payment.
And a week before the first
vaccinations in the world
began in the UK, INTERPOL warned
that criminal organizations
were planning to infiltrate and disrupt
the vaccine supply chain.
Hackers are looking for a way
to tamper with the distribution.
The cold chain network
that enables the delivery
of temperature sensitive
COVID-19 vaccines,
like the one developed
by Pfizer and BioNTech,
that has to be kept at
-70 degrees Celsius.
- The payoffs are really big.
The people that are doing it
are increasingly sophisticated.
- [Narrator] So are hackers
targeting the vaccine rollout
and is there a way to stop them?
Hackers have been honing
their skills for years
by going after hospitals.
- The average hospital doesn't
have very good cybersecurity.
Criminals are eager to take advantage
of the concern that the virus has raised.
- [Narrator] Jim Lewis
leads a cybersecurity team
into a Washington based think tank.
He says the easiest tool
for hackers is phishing.
- You send an email out
to a hundred people,
the odds are very good that
two of them will click on it.
What the COVID vaccine creates
is the opportunity to do
this on a massive scale
and that means you can
ask for a massive ransom.
- [Narrator] If someone
clicks on a malicious link
or opens an attachment,
the person may be prompted
to download malware
or enter login details,
giving the attacker access
to the network and its data.
During the pandemic, phishers setup bait
with emails sent to hospitals
about COVID-19 prevention
and setting up pandemic funds.
And now that the vaccines
are on their way,
hackers are taking on new identities
to infiltrate cold chain companies,
like ones that manufacture solar panels
to power refrigerators or IT firms
that support biotech and
pharmaceutical clients.
- I think the messages were
very specifically crafted
to get people at these
companies to respond
but in general, this whole
problem of Corona virus
being a lure for scammers is huge.
- [Narrator] IBM recently tracked down
a phishing campaign that targeted
a variety of these companies.
The hacker was disguised
as a project manager
from the Chinese company, Haier Biomedical
which, his website says,
is the world's only complete
cold chain provider.
The writer said it would send an
advance payment of around $220,000.
The message went on to ask that the reader
review the attached draft contract,
which is actually a malicious attachment.
IBM says it's unclear if any victims
clicked on the file and fell for this scam
and doesn't know which nation
state might be behind it.
If there were any victims,
IBM says the harvested credentials
could give the hacker insight
into internal communications
as well as methods and plans
to distribute the COVID-19 vaccine.
Haier Biomedical says it
condemns the perpetrators
of the phishing email
and is working with
international organizations
to ensure that these incidents
don't deter the fight
against the pandemic.
But if hackers do successfully
access the system,
they can encrypt the data,
making it unreadable.
This can happen to logistics companies
responsible for delivering the vaccine.
- And so you could imagine a
locking up the supply chain,
locking up distribution
codes, or locking the trucks
and saying, unless you pay,
you won't be able to deliver.
- [Narrator] But some
systems in the cold chain
would be harder to hack.
- Yeah, the actual
operation of a refrigerator,
that would be a specialized
operating system
and that would be configured
in a way that was unusual so
they have to figure out how they work.
- [Narrator] So what's
more likely to happen
is that hackers will go
after low hanging fruit.
- They're already making tons of money
just hitting standard
windows operating machines.
So if you were working for
a refrigeration company,
I'd be worried about the sort
of the back office equipment
that the salespeople use,
the laptops and the desktops
and maybe some of the servers.
- [Narrator] After all,
according to a survey
by a healthcare IT consultant,
80% of health professionals
say their hospitals
still use legacy systems,
such as Windows 2008.
- You need to do basic cyber hygiene
which includes training,
two factor authentication,
making sure your patches
and updates are installed,
but on top of that, you
need to back up your data
and think about how you're
gonna use cloud services.
- [Narrator] But given the high stakes
of getting more people vaccinated,
no amount of drills may
prepare the cold chain
for the months to come.
- This has changed from
efforts to steal the formula,
to efforts to blackmail
people about distribution.
So we're seeing the cyber crime evolve
when it comes to COVID.